hi everyone my name is presently a
mechanical engineer and absolute clear
data science enthusiast I was doing a
lots of research to deep dive into this
field and I wanted a very different
curriculum and that's how I found simply
done and this started off my journey
towards data science and yeah when I
think about the current situation of
over ninety pandemic going on I think
this is the best time to pose your
interest there are many things we want
to do like binge watching
controversial news and more but I think
this is the best time that you can
upscale yourself so I prepared myself up
and I completed my certification in
tableau our Python machine learning Big
Data and taboo in just 2.5 months which
in normal course would have taken around
six months so whosoever is listening I
would really suggest you to can go to a
confined program because more than
anything it gives you the same thing
when I talk about simply learn I would
really commend them for the quality of
faculties they have brought to the table
the faculties in the live sessions are
very good and their explanation are good
as well for me it was like my good
mentorship because all the queries I can
get all the queries solved right away
and the support team are all wonderful
and when I was doing the projects they
were very helpful as well
getting the basics and added practice in
the course I am really moving forward
toward doing more projects on platforms
like cattle makeover - the way I'm
moving forward I feel really confident
last but not the least I really want to
thank simply done and to all the
learners out there be safe stay inside
home and start running from home happy
narrating
[Music]